ufo anhörung im us-kongress und dort
fällt tatsächlich dieser satz hier
irgendetwas ist da draußen das pentagon
kann von 144 beschriebenen unheimlichen
begegnungen nur eine erklären alle
anderen phänomene bleiben mysteriös
ein ufo ein wetterphänomen immer wieder
sichten menschen auf der ganzen welt
unerklärliche himmelserscheinungen viele
sind sogar überzeugt es handelt sich um
ufos
[Musik]
das licht am himmel ich bin nicht sicher
was es ist aber haben wir es mit
außerirdischen zu tun oder gibt es für
all das nicht doch eine logische
erklärung in den usa will man nun licht
ins dunkel bringen
[Musik]
denn in den letzten jahrzehnten begegnen
auch us-militär piloten immer wieder
unbekannten flugobjekten die in
unglaublicher geschwindigkeit plötzlich
die richtung wechselten oder abrupt
stoppen
leute das ist das ende
[Musik]
der us-geheimdienst ist sich sicher
diese technologie gehört nicht uns das
problem die videos der vermeintlichen
ufos sind meist nur wenige sekunden lang
und auf den schnipseln lässt sich nur
schwer etwas erkennen die auswertung
schwierig der appell des us kongresses
an alle militärpiloten wenn ihr etwas
ungewöhnliches seht meldet es
144 berichte haben amerikanische
geheimdienste und das
verteidigungsministerium jetzt
hochoffiziell ausgewertet und siehe da
einige wenige videos können sich selbst
die behörden tatsächlich nicht erklären
und mittlerweile sind schon wieder gut
250 neue berichte dazu gekommen